marie-eve les djihadistes donc ont pris
le contrôle de la ville hier c'était un
coup terrible pour la population qui est
déjà éprouvée par des années de guerre
civile contre le régime de bachar al
assad et les gens se retrouvent coincés
dans un étau aujourd'hui voilà selon les
nations unies environ tiers des gens qui
se trouvaient à palmyre ont réussi à
fuir avant la prise de contrôle totale
par le lit mais il ya des gens qui ont
essayé de fuir selon les nations unies
selon des gens qui j'ai parlé aussi
qu'ils ont été empêchés par les forces
du régime de bachar al assad avant qu'il
ne fuie eux mêmes leurs positions autour
de palmyre maintenant les gens se disent
un peu coincé entre deux feux les
bombardements du régime syrien ont
repris alors on trinque ce ne soit des
civils qui en paient le prix fort et un
activiste anti régime qui étapes à venir
à qui j'ai parlé m'a dit avoir vu de ses
propres yeux des combattants de le y
allaient de maison en maison à la
recherche de gens qui soutiennent le
régime de bachar al assad
plusieurs d'entre eux ont déjà étaient
assassinés les hommes ont eu la tête
tranchée
les femmes ont été exécutés sommairement
avec une balle dans la tête tout ça donc
est très inquiétant pour cette
population
oui très inquiétant palmyre c'est une
ville qui est entouré de désert mais ça
reste quand même une ville d'une très
grande importance stratégique voit
d'abord protéger parce qu'elle
représente la porte d'entrée sur de très
grands champs de gaz des ressources
naturelles très importante dans ce sont
maintenant emparés le groupe armé état
islamique stratégique aussi du point de
vue de la géographie parce qu'elle
permet faire le pont avec des
territoires qui ont été confiés aussi
par le hit du côté de l'irak cette fois
on pense à la province d'al-anbar il
conquis la capitale ramadi ce dimanche
est stratégique parce que c'est un point
idéal pour pouvoir lancer d'autres
francis gasnier de plus en plus de
terrain on pense dans l'immédiat la
ville de homs qui est la troisième ville
en importance à sir en syrie était aussi
sur la route vers damas la capitale
bon évidemment ces avancées des
djihadistes soulève toutes sortes de
questions sur la stratégie militaire des
états unis bien sûr mais aussi du canada
voilà parce que pendant que le groupe
hermitage islamique faisait tous ses
gains assez spectaculaire les avions de
la coalition ont bombardé ce qui fait se
demander à plusieurs pourquoi est ce
qu'ils n'ont pas pu empêcher les villes
de tomber ce n'était pas une surprise
les américains ont tenté avec les
bombardements par exemple de freiner le
groupe hermitage islamique à ramadi en
vain du côté de la syrie pendant que les
combattants s'emparait de palmyre le
canada a affirmé avoir frappé deux
positions de lits en syrie mais dans la
ville de raqqa qui est leur fief
alors ça fait se demander aux gens
pourquoi est ce qu'on ne peut pas réagir
plus rapidement pour empêcher leur
avancée
mais surtout ça pose la question sur la
capacité au sol des forces qui sont en
charge du combat contre le groupe armé
islamique de mener ce combat
les états unis avaient promis
d'entraîner des milices sunnites entre
autres pour éviter les conflits
confessionnels pour lutter contre lui
évidemment ça ne va pas assez rapidement
avec tout ce qu'on voit au cours de la
dernière semaine
merci marie-eve pour toutes ces
informations
merci au revoir à cannes t'imagines des
droits au niveau 6 premiers animaux et
roumaine était la directrice générale de
l'unesco qui craint le pire
la ville de pamiers abrite les ruines de
l'un des plus grand foyer culturel du
monde antique pas devenir une grande
oasis caravanières a connu la prospérité
sous le contrôle de rome au 1er siècle
c'était un carrefour commercial qui
reliait la perse l'inde la chine à
l'empiré romain
son architecture rappelle son histoire
parmi les ruines qui témoigne de la
grandeur de la cité la grande colonnades
longue de plus d'un kilomètre ceylac ce
monumental qui relie
les monuments publics comme par exemple
temple/lot bell l'un des plus importants
monuments religieux en orient il ya
aussi le camp dioclétien l'agora et le
théâtre